Katy tur of NBC her book unbelievable my
front row seat to the craziest campaign
in American history Katy tur reading
this book there didn't seem to be much
of a filter on it is that a fair
assessment no and that was on purpose
because this was not coverage of the
political campaign that I was following
it's not what happened in the Donald
Trump orbit for every decision that they
made this was a book about what it was
like as a journalist to be there and to
see it up close to show America what we
do for a living the the hardships we go
through the long days the longer nights
the interactions we have with the
campaign the interactions we have with
supporters so it's it had few muris
lighthearted moments but then also very
dark moments in very trying moments
because this was I mean how do you be
filtered about what happened in 2016 it
was so unbelievable one of the things
that used say during them throughout the
book is don't count him out that you
were sensing something out there in the
country I don't think you anybody should
have and that's why I don't think anyone
should count him out even today yes his
poll numbers are low historically low
for a president this early in his first
term and yes he still says outrageous
things and he's plagued by negative
headlines and scandals and a federal
investigation but Donald Trump enjoys
support like nobody else has I mean
people like him not despite all of the
many controversies but but because of
them they liked it he's fighting they
they have a pugilistic nature in
themselves that donald trump represents
and that was discounted very early on
and it was pervasive people were
discounting him the night of election
night November 8 it's when when even
when it even when the the the momentum
was swing into his direction people were
saying oh no the urban vote is going to
come in and it's gonna it's gonna kill
him and it just didn't happen that way
Katie turn in your book also you you
think the Trump supporters who were nice
to you you thanked the Trump officials
who gave you access to information did
you experience that throughout the
campaign I mean we all know kind of the
bad side no I I don't think anyone
should paint anybody with a broad brush
and that goes for the campaign it also
goes for Donald Trump supporters there
are campaign staffers who I have a very
good relationship with there are
campaign staffers who I don't have a
very good relationship with that's
normal for a reporter covering anybody
in politics because politicians don't
like the journalists that are covering
them because we expose things they don't
want exposed we fact-checked them when
they don't want to be fact-check we
correct spin we contextualize our
coverage is not always fawning it's not
supposed to be funny so there's always
going to be that push-pull and I had
some really lovely and positive
interactions with Donald Trump
supporters as well people who helped me
curl my hair in the bathroom at one
rally but it was it was so bizarre and
so surreal because at the same time
there were so many supporters who were
calling on a calling members of the
media liars screaming at us at the top
of our lungs giving us the finger
threatening our lives I had death
threats during the campaign because
Donald Trump you know riled them up and
told them what Liars we were so they
took out a lot of their anger that they
had pent up on on members of the press
anger towards the establishment anger
towards the status quo anger towards
Congress and Washington and the way
things always work and they were able to
take it out on
those in the media who were offended at
each one of these rallies 202 is the
area code if you want to talk to Katy
tur about her book unbelievable 7 4 8
8200 for those of you in the East and
Central time zones - OH - 7 4 8 8 - 0 1
if you live in the mountain and Pacific
time zones and you talk about the press
pen it really is a pen yeah yeah it's an
area that's usually in the center of the
rally
that's cordoned off by bicycle racks
which just come up to about your waist
and we would have them in the in the
center of a basketball arena in Grand
Rapids Michigan with five six thousand
people surrounding us on all sides they
would be in the center but up against a
wall with supporters on all sides of us
in the belly of a world war two warship
a battleship we could come and go as we
please when Donald Trump wasn't there
but for some reason which was never
fully explained by the campaign they
would force us to be inside the pen and
not to leave whenever Donald Trump was
in the room and the Secret Service for
reasons we still don't understand abided
by this since the Secret Service is paid
by the public it didn't really make
sense that they were following
directions of the campaign for how the
press behaved I think it was probably at
least partially because Donald Trump
didn't want reporters asking him
questions on the rope line but then
there was also a theory that was posited
after the campaign which was actually
very interesting that basically we were
there as part of the act part of the
show Donald Trump brought in members of
the elites members of the establishment
and paged them up in the middle of the
rally so that when he turned on us
he allowed everybody in the room to turn
on us to get there a guy can get their
aggression their frustration out on this
little slice of what was wrong with
politics and wrong with America in his
mind in their mind that he brought in to
show his his rally go
two questions is the press a legitimate
target and was there a legitimate
argument in there that Donald Trump was
making in your view the press sure you
could say the press is a target if you
don't want to trust what they're saying
but that's I don't think religion emmett
no I take that back we're not a
legitimate target because without
journalists it's just propaganda
politicians telling you whatever they
believe whatever they think you should
hear I mean they're doing it because
it's they're not there maybe their own
self-interest but it's their interests
that they're preserving and I don't
think you should just trust whatever a
politician says on face value I just
don't think that's healthy that's not
the way our democracy was set up it's
not what our our founders had envisioned
there's a Fourth Estate to put checks
and balances on on lawmakers on our on
our politicians so you need a free press
for a healthy and functioning democracy
a word cheap target not a fair target we
are a cheap target for politicians who
don't want to be held accountable did he
have some merit to say that we were a
bunch of liars and scum
no Kate eater is our guest and the first
call comes from will Will's calling in
from Powell's Point North Carolina will
you're on book TV question or comment
please yes
we're listening okay okay good I have a
question in regards to on some sense you
mentioned that the Miami from book deal
earlier and it's it has to do with the
the difference between fact-checking as
such and building a context for those
facts and the question is do you think
that it would be fair that at times the
media can contextualize facts that may
or may not be true to the point that
they either become false or true and
that that would be a valid criticism of
the media the contextualization of facts
or non facts rather than stating things
to be factual or not well here's the
thing about facts they are facts an
apple is an apple and
orange is an orange gravity exists facts
are facts are not subjective so you
can't contextualize a fact and make it
true or not true and I'm trying to
understand your question but I think
maybe what you're saying is can we sway
opinion by the the the way in which we
describe something that's not our
intention we we tried to to put Donald
Trump in context for those who had come
before him and for what most politicians
had done and also when he would say
something that wasn't true
you can fact check it you can say well
that's not sure but maybe it wasn't
maybe part of it was true what part of
it wasn't true said you contextualize
and you say you know Donald Trump is
calling a federal judge unfair because
he's Mexican well the context there is
he's of Mexican heritage and we should
point that out and the context is this
is a man who is presiding over the Trump
University case and there are rulings
that he doesn't like and the context is
Donald Trump is has always pushed back
on things that he doesn't like and he's
trying to sway public opinion to push
back on the idea that his university was
was a fraud which was what prosecutors
were saying about it and what defendants
on defendants and the people who
participated in it were saying about it
those who were trying to get their money
back and that's just one example but I'm
curious to find for you to give me an
example of where you thought we were we
were tipping the scales in one way or
another and will is gone unfortunately
we will talk to Bob in Maple Springs New
York Bob you're on with Katy tur the
bubble I'm very glad to be on with her
hey my wife has read the book I'm
reading the book we feel like we know
you we spend a lot of time with you and
we feel you've been very honest in your
book have you gotten any negative
feedback from people the way you
portrayed them in the book things that
they said or
the things that you attributed to them
any negative feedback no not
surprisingly but no I I have not I've
talked to a number of people who appear
in the book or or they're the source
information for a lot of my reporting in
the book and and I've said we're only
gun positive responses I haven't gotten
anything negative although Donald Trump
although he didn't you know name the
book he did tweet about it the day it
came out and and basically some tweeted
and he said that I know fascinating to
see journalists who know nothing about
me right major books so that's maybe the
most negative response I've gotten but
again he didn't read the book of it I
mean it came out came out that day have
you seen him talked to him since the
election I have not spoken to him since
the election though why didn't you go to
the White House wasn't that isn't that
the usual path um I didn't go to the
White House because I there was a number
of reasons one I it was very personal I
wanted to have a life I you know you you
do this a lot in this business where you
blow up personal relationships in order
to pursue your career and in order to
pursue this campaign to follow this
campaign I blew up a relationship I had
overseas and and I had one I've
developed one here and and got serious
and I wanted I didn't I wanted to get
married so I stayed in New York and then
you get married I did get married three
weeks ago three weeks ago graduations
thank you very much and then secondly I
I believe that what was really
beneficial to me during the campaign was
that I was an outsider it wasn't part of
the Washington
swamp quote quote unquote enough to say
that it's a swamp but reporters who live
there have a certain set of preconceived
notions a bit of baggage about how
Washington works and what I was able to
do on the campaign trail was to take a
look at it with a pair of fresh eyes and
really judge and engage with the support
without all of the the rules of
Washington behind me and I wanted to
maintain that especially going into 2020
next call for Katy tur is Ronald right
down here in Hollywood Florida hi Ronald
go ahead American voters as you travel
around do you think that the American
voters are educated enough I do they
follow the issues is this a popularity
contest now I can remember I'm in my
sixties and I can remember we are prior
to in elections people were more
concerned with issues and they read
stuff you know the media was a positive
thing but now it seemed to be a
publicity a public thing where you know
I'm popular I don't like this candidate
but we don't deal with the issues and so
that's my concern what is your
assessment Thank You Ronald that's a
really good question I think that we as
a country need to be more educated in
the process of our politics and our
elections the process of journalism our
policies and the issues I think there
can be a bit of tunnel vision
at times too just deciding you like
somebody you like the way they speak and
so you're not going to hear anything
else and that's on both sides of the
aisle and you've decided that the other
the other candidate is is evil or a liar
or all of the the negative attributes
you can think to attribute to that
person I I don't think we are as
issue-based as as we could be and I mean
part of that is just American culture a
part of that is
the advent of television they talked
about it was talked about when when TV
was invented and when they first started
airing debates and politicians live that
sudden that we saw people who were a
little bit more TV friendly than
politicians in the past so I think
that's a failing but but you are right I
mean their policy took a took a backseat
during this campaign especially Donald
Trump did not have a lot of policy
behind him he did talk about policy a
lot he talked about building a wall and
deporting illegal immigrants and you
know having a Muslim ban but these were
mostly having to do with immigration and
they were really broad strokes it wasn't
the nitty-gritty of here is how I'm
going to get things done and I think
that is to our the fact that we didn't
talk about it more is certainly to our
detriment
Michael Laughlin Nevada hi Michael hello
and congratulations Katie on your
wedding I was like you're welcome I
would like to know how difficult was it
for you to get access through sourcing
or to sources through the campaign
through the Trump campaign people I seen
that you retreat fish asleep to the
rhetoric and you know I got a commend
you on your bravery and I was just
curious how difficult was it was it for
you to get interviews so that first pull
your sword thing I mean was it really
that tough on you and go ahead okay
thank you Michael
it was it's always difficult to get to
know a group of people to to build
sources I mean but that's part of the
job but you you become more skilled that
hasn't added as you go along and what it
is is a series of relationships in the
building of trust can we speak in an
honest and direct manner are you going
to tell me the truth when I ask few
questions are we going to be honest when
you really don't know something and and
can the source trust that when we say
something is off the record or something
is on background which basically means
we won't name you that that remains that
way that you don't reveal sources
they're able to talk freely so that's
that's just a that's a process it takes
time it takes getting to know people
every campaign is difficult for a
reporter to to penetrate this campaign
was more difficult than most I think it
was difficult for all of us not just me
but you learn who you can talk to and
who you can't talk to who you can trust
even off the record or on background and
who you can't trust and when they don't
give you access when they don't tell you
things that can be very illuminating in
itself because you you learn to you
start to figure out why they don't want
to talk about a certain thing or why
they might shut down at this certain
time or who they talk to
so it's all just about you know you can
get a feel for it and you learn how to
navigate where was that point that you
were truly frightened for your life I
mean the most obvious answer to that
question is the day of the Muslim ban
but it happened even earlier than that I
did a sit-down interview with Donald
Trump in the in Trump Tower and Joe in
July and it got really contentious and
who was going to Phoenix right after
that
and at this point I had very few
followers on Twitter so when somebody
would tweet me I would see it
immediately and there was one man who
was saying very aggressive things and
are you going to Arizona I'm gonna find
you I'm gonna find you I'm gonna tell
you what I think and you know I'm
paraphrasing but stuff that that made me
nervous so when I was in Arizona even
early on this was in July I was really
cognizant of who was around me and I was
on edge I was lookin perros in the back
of my neck were standing up ever right
and go to the pressed pen in that rally
cuz I was scared that the guy would
would see who I was I have never
experienced anything like that before as
a reporter I mean you just you didn't
get threatened as a reporter you I
covered
I covered fires and shootings and
terrorism and natural disasters and
happy stories human interests I had
never covered something with such fiery
and sensitive emotion so early on but I
got I got kind of used to that pretty
quickly but the day of the the Muslim
man when he called me out from stage
after he had already been tweeting that
I should be fired for reporting that he
factual reporting that he didn't like in
that room at that moment in time I felt
super nervous and the campaign felt
nervous for me one of the staffers
arranged for a Secret Service to walk me
to my car next call for Katy tur comes
from Allegra Daly City California
good afternoon Allegra please go ahead
yes good afternoon
a Teeter life and watching you since
beginning of a campaign I remember when
Barbara Walters want to discuss politics
she was on NBC and I believe that Today
Show and she was sort of told to stick
to fashion Hollywood but she was
ambitious and she was going to do this
and I started watching MSNBC at the
beginning of the campaign because of you
and the other young women who were going
around the
three during the campaign I worried
about you
really I I worried that someone was
going to abuse you I went to the Wharton
School also later than Donald Trump and
I got my MBA and he came up to me once
at a function in New York and said I
didn't know women can get their MBAs and
I said mr. Trump yes they came out but
let me tell you in 1976 it was really
hot and I wish that once in awhile you
would have older women hunting their
shows we can explain to you why there
are men like Donald Trump
Harvey Weinstein Bill Clinton we admired
you so very very much I watch you every
day and my father Allegra think do you
know what we're gonna leave your couple
your comment there thank you very much
for calling thank you very much was
there in your view something sexist and
calling you out I'll leave that for
individuals to decide he does use
different language for women than he
uses for men he called me out a lot but
he called me out that starting from the
very first day I was ever at a rally
really early on it in June of 2015 and
that continued throughout the campaign
and I think that it needs to at least
partially be attributed to the fact that
I was the first network correspondent to
be assigned to his campaign full-time so
he knew he knew me early on and for a
while I was the only correspondent that
he would recognize in a crowd of people
so we had a lot of one-on-one
interaction so NBC News he he had worked
with NBC on The Apprentice so I think he
wanted and probably expected nicer
coverage from us and he wasn't getting
it and and I was you know
young ish now I guess I'm young I was
younger when this started I had not
covered politics I'm a small woman I'm
5-2 and maybe he thought that he could
either charm me into being friendlier or
steamroll me and intimidate me into
being friendlier that doesn't work not
with me Jean
st. Louis we have one minute left go
ahead I wonder if anyone from your
network any executive ever approached
the campaign or the candidate about his
calling you out in public and the
concerns that raised and if so what was
the campaign or the candidates response
they the network actually did that a
number of times say we stop we don't
think this is appropriate you're
endangering our reporter I had to have
armed guards I guess from the bodyguards
with me during almost a good I think
half of the campaign after January or so
and all the other Trump reporters as
well no matter where we went so they
were not happy about that they thought
that that was completely inappropriate
for a political journalist to be
targeted for covering a political
campaign
the campaign's response to them I don't
know I was I wasn't privy to it but I
will say that I was talking to one of
the staffers about the way he was
talking about reporters in general and
and the the danger that he was putting
reporters in and the serious concern
that anybody in the press for me anyone
else might get hurt outside of a rally
inside of a rally that someone might
decide to to to take it out on us or
take it one step too far
and I asked the staffer if Donald Trump
knew what he was doing and the stepford
said yeah and I said well does he care
and the Zephyr said no
I don't know if he maybe just didn't
think it was as serious as we were
saying it was I don't know
Katie turd did you ever hear from Brian
Roberts from edging become Casa Loma
during the campaign
no but I've talked to him afterwards
Katie ters book is unbelievable it's
about the 2016 election my front row
seat to the craziest campaign in
American history where was a picture on
the front of this taken this is actually
very interesting it's in the the Trump
Hotel while it was under construction he
tried to give the press a tour of the
hotel and we just wanted to talk to him
about whatever was happening at that
moment which is escaping me I believe
this is I think it's a ride honestly I
think it's around the time he was saying
that the families of terrorists should
be should be targets as well to be
killed as well I think I'm asking about
that in that photo thanks for being our
guest on book TV thanks so much for
having me